give the floor first to the president of
the european council thank you
thank you
good afternoon everyone we just
participated in the virtual g7 leaders
meeting of on afghanistan
first we tackled what remains our most
pressing priority the safe evacuation of
the coalition citizens afghan staff and
their families
the eu and its member states spare no
effort to evacuate eu citizens and those
who have partnered trustfully with us
and we are concerned about the ability
to safely reach the kabul airport we
call on the new afghan authorities to
allow free passage to all foreign and
afghan citizens who wish to get to the
airport
we have also raised this issue with our
american friends and partners on two
particular aspects
first the need to secure the airport as
slant as necessary to complete the
operations
and seconds
a fair and equitable access to the
airport for all nationals entitled to
evacuation
on humanitarian and migration
i'll just make two remarks first the eu
will do its part to support the safety
and proper living conditions of africans
who flee their country
we will work with countries in the
region especially iran pakistan and
central asia to address the different
needs
international protection will be needed
for those facing persecution and for
other vulnerable afghans
and eu member states will contribute to
this international effort
second point
let's be clear
let's not allow the creation of a new
market for smugglers and human
traffickers
and you are determined to keep the
migratory flows under control and the
eu's borders protect it
today
it's too early to decide what kind of
relations will develop with the new
afghan authorities
we call for an inclusive political
settlement and
if we want to remain a positive
influence for the afghan people
especially in supporting their basic
needs we'll have to deal with the new
authorities
and this will be subject to strict
conditions regarding the deeds
and attitude of the new regime
both in preserving the political
economic and social achievements for the
afghan citizens and the human rights
notably of women girls and minorities
and in terms of the international
obligations of afghanistan in particular
security the fight against terrorism and
drug trafficking
on security the cooperation between nato
and other allies will be key
sharing data
among allies and partners to prevent
entry of foreign terrorist fighters
which also play an important role
finally on the geopolitical implications
of these events
ending the military operation in
afghanistan is not the end of our
commitment to promoting rule of law
and human rights in the world
on the contrary we must be more
determined than ever this must be clear
to actors who are trying to take
advantage of the current situation
the eu will continue to firmly protect
and promote its interest in values and
to conclude
there will be more lessons to draw
from what happened in afghanistan
these events show
that developing our strategic autonomy
while keeping our alliances as strong as
ever is of the utmost importance for the
future of europe
in due time i'd propose a distinction on
this situation to my fellow leaders of
the european council i thank you
thank you mr president madam president
please thank you very much before
entering into the subject i would like
to thank
our colleagues from the external action
service for their hard and dedicated
work
over the last days
and also the strong support we got from
the member states
especially france italy belgium and
spain concerning the evacuation of the
eu delegation and the afghan staff
so i'm very grateful that most of the
eu's staff and including the afghan
staff including their families have been
evacuated now from afghanistan and are
safe
now turning towards the g7 we just had
um first of all
i want to thank the united kingdom
presidency for convening this meeting we
all agreed that it is our moral duty
to help the afghan people and to provide
as much as possible support as
conditions allow
the situation is indeed a tragedy for
the afghan people and it is a major
setback for the international community
it was therefore timely that the g7 met
and it was very good that we had as
guests the nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg
and the un secretary general antonio
guterres
in this meeting of the g7 we discussed
evacuations
immediate humanitarian aid longer-term
development assistance
and possible scenarios for refugees in
need of protection
on the humanitarian aid
let me tell you that our key eu
operations on medical facilities food
distribution emergency water supply
and sanitation are mostly still running
that is good but of course the events we
see these days create significant
additional needs
we need to help mostly those who are at
immediate risk
and those are women girls and children
who make up the vast majority of
internally displaced people 80 percent
of the internally displaced people in
afghanistan are women and girls
and up to now
the number runs up to around 3.7 million
internally displaced people in
afghanistan
and this is why there was broad
determination
to step up contribution in humanitarian
aid
i announced that the commission will
propose to almost quadruple
the humanitarian aid coming from the eu
budget
we had planned initially for more than
50 million for the year 2021
we will now increase it to over 200
million euros for the year 2021
and this will help meet the urgent needs
of afghans both in afghanistan but also
of course in the neighboring host
countries
the second topic i want to address is
the discussion about the development
assistance
i and many others stressed
that the future development assistance
has to be condition
it always is condition-based
linked to fundamental values human
rights of course women's rights
and um it is self-speaking that
the development assistance of the future
has also to be strictly condition based
as you might know we have one billion
euros set aside for the next seven years
for afghanistan in the eu development
assistance
this aid is now
frozen and it is frozen until we have
solid guarantees and credible actions on
the ground
that the conditions are being met
finally on migration
as i said the people most at risks are
educated women are girls
female journalists human rights
activists female teacher judges lawyers
just to name some
50 countries took part in the isaf nato
mission
and 36 countries took part in resolute
support mission
so to protect
these most vulnerable
is clearly a matter for global
cooperation it has to be dealt as such
from the start
these people should not fall into
smugglers hands they need safe pathways
and therefore i welcome that during the
g7
canada announced and the uk announced
significant numbers for resettlement 21
000 respective to 20 000
also the
united states
announced their commitment for
resettlement
it is important that this issue as it
has to be dealt on a global level
um is coordinated and it is good that we
have in place
the resettlement forum
the resettlement form in which not only
the commission and member states are but
also the unihcr the iom the united
states canada and there we can
coordinate resettlement efforts
in the manner it is needed now in this
acute situation
i think beyond those i've just
being
i have just named all other countries
who took part in the nato mission should
contribute to this effort too the
european union is ready to play its role
too
we are looking into necessary budgetary
means to support eu member states who
will step up and help resettle
alongside these very targeted measures
for well-defined group our main effort
should be
to ensure that as i've said internally
displaced afghans are supported or the
international community contributes to
their support in the neighboring
countries
so the support also for the region is of
utmost importance
and therefore we will continue of course
also as a european union to work with
the countries in the immediate region
finally let me stress once again
that these events we
see these days
all underline the urgent need for the
member states and the european
parliament to find an agreement on our
proposed pact of migration and asylum
we need a fully functioning system in
place that allows us to effectively
manage our borders
to ensure solidarity between member
states and to cooperate with countries
of origin origin and transit
merci
thank you madam president
we'll first take a few questions here in
the press room and i'll start with
lailuma sadid
correspondent for afghan news please
it's a bit too high apparently the
microphone take the microphone
thank you very much should i remove the
mask
it's okay okay
as an afghan journalist i'm the only one
to work
for afghan media unfortunately for the
moment you know the situation but i'm
correspondent also for brussels morning
i would like to ask how many more
policies
felt
follow-up to arrive in the good
workable one
with whom for the moment would you like
to make
decision
to see what is going on for afghanistan
and
also to recognition the taliban
without any condition i think it will be
again the other mistake that the
european doing for the afghans
and also the second question if i may
ask you said that
you start
making some help for the afghans out of
the country for example in pakistan
as i remember it very well during the
past during the mujahideen regime
you helped not only eu all the world
helped a lot for the refugees in
pakistan but they built madrasas they
built the extremely tourist group there
and they came back and we see they have
relation with this
tourist group al-qaeda and all this kind
of
person in the world and once again if
this time this please keep it focused
what is your second question please yeah
my second question is
without any condition please don't
recognize the taliban think about the
woman and also for the other activists
in afghanistan thank you very much
we we all agree it was very clear during
this g7 meeting that it's um very
fundamental to express a clear message
from the international community and
this g7 meeting is an important first
step but it follows also important
meetings and the level of security
council of the united nations and
antonio guterres participated also in
this g7 meeting and in our opinion uh
the eu with the support of all our
member states we are totally convinced
that we should be very clear on
different points first of all we need to
guarantee the free access for the
humanitarian aid in order to support the
people in afghanistan.1.2
we can see that it's very important to
guarantee that the fight against the
international terrorism and the
terrorist in general will be a clear
priority 0.3 we have worked a lot in
order to promote the fundamental values
human rights the potential the
production of human of women rights and
and and the rights of the of the girls
and also the rights of the minorities it
must
be a priority well very clear on that
and also uh the fight against the druid
trafficking is also an important element
and with the g7 colleagues we agreed to
real world very closely with them in
order to express a very clear message
but it's also needed to work with other
members of the international community
mario draghi is the president of the g20
because italy has the presidency of the
g20
he planned uh if he plans plants
some initiatives in the framework of the
g20 and we also think that we need to
speak with other members of the
international community in order to give
a very strong
message
we are also very clear we have only
operational contacts with the taliban
and this is needed in order to make sure
that we can
provide a safe evacuation as much as
possible and the next days will remain a
key and
for the eu
it's very clear that the first priority
is to make sure that the conditions that
i've mentioned will be fulfilled
yes thank you
indeed the
purpose of this meeting was to
coordinate
and to create unity and that was
successful
and indeed we touched on many topics but
also on those you were mentioning
very clearly it is
um for us
uh they are very clear preconditions
uh to talks with the taliban and as sean
michel said there are operational talks
that are necessary
for
the the daily
proceedings around kabul and the airport
but this is completely separated from
political talks or any question of
recognition
and the g7 was and is very clear
that we have a very strict conditions
um and that we stay united in the
question of
a
recognition that is not on the table
with the taliban the second topic is yes
we have to work with the countries in
the region
we have to work with the countries in
the region because of
the afghan refugees that are there and
that needs support and here indeed the
g20 uh forum is certainly also the right
room to discuss broader questions in a
different manner um so
xiaomi shell just said
that
mario draghi is of course being a member
of g7 in light of g7
i'm certain that there will
be steps following
and lastly thank you very much for your
question
on women that need now help
the focus has to be on the women
to get the women in safety now
and we know who they are
there's an enormous effort in the
international community and i witness is
it by the hour every day
to protect and to get those women out of
afghanistan therefore this resettlement
coordination is so important and the
message has to be very clear
we know who they are we know how much
they have been fighting at by our side
we know how exposed they are
and therefore they need protection
absolutely the whole focus has to be on
that now
thank you madam president
thomas
frankfurter argument
um thanks a lot um
a question first of all to you president
michel you've said that the kabul
airport needs to be
secured as long as
it's necessary did you get any
commitment on that
by president biden
president
the taliban
i can i can confirm that
several leaders during the g7 meeting
have expressed concerns about this
timing the uh the 31st of uh august and
we had also the opportunity uh to to to
express our opinion on that also because
we are in close contact with prime
ministers head of state at the european
level and they told us that for them
it's very important to try to extend
this timing don't intend to speak on
behalf the president of the united
states but we had the opportunity to
exchange views about this topic point
one and point two um after
uh later the 21st or later we will see
in any case it will be key to guarantee
safe passages in order to make sure it
will be that it will be possible in the
future for afghans to leave the country
when it will be needed and that's why
also we are very current we are in
contact with countries in the region in
the neighboring with the neighboring
countries in order also to be in
dialogue with them we discussed also the
situation the state use of the airport
in kabul now to see how in the future it
should be possible to guarantee that the
human the humanitarian aid will have
access to the country and we know that
an airport is always an important
infrastructure in order to guarantee
assist a safe access for the human and
humanitarian aid
yeah film dank
[Music]
we have lawrence norman connected
virtually
lawrence you have the floor
uh
thank you very much
i'm gonna just chase up on the secret
you almost a little bit
can you with respect lauren i'm sorry to
intervene sorry the sound is not very
good could you please approach or speak
clearly
to the camera to the microphone please
i'll try again is that better
it's it's quite
far
okay
go go on
we'll come back to you laurence i'll go
to dave clark from
afp dave you're next
hello is my audio clearer yes we can
hear you
perfectly
okay thank you very much
uh you've spoken uh of your moral
obligation to help vulnerable afghans
beyond your own staff and
their relatives obviously the window is
closing at kabul airport now
uh the uh there will be uh human rights
activists women's rights activists ngo
workers artists journalists who won't
get out this week obviously there will
have to be a resettlement plan for them
uh how long will it take
to arrange this
and uh how large do you foresee it being
yes
so um
most important is here the very close
cooperation that fits to the question i
just got before that to a very close
cooperation with unhcr
because they are the ones who know
best about how to proceed
we should not forget
that
we are in
a trans transitory phase
where we should not underestimate that
we have some leverage
afghanistan
is a poor country
there's an enormous need of support
they have horrible droughts
cavities in the country too
just to name a few topics
and the humanitarian aid will be there
and is there but it also is a
possibility to be in contact
with
the the people in power
to make understood that for a certain
group
we need unconditional access
and we need to be able to support with
all means
as i've outlined with the humanitarian
aid
to get people out of the country
my experience is the best is to work
with the united nations who are
experienced the unhcr the iom they know
exactly what's going on
thank you beatrice beatrice rios
thank you for that
can you hear me perfectly yes that's
great uh it's a little bit of a
follow-up to dave's question i was
wondering if the commission is going to
make a concrete pledge uh of that
resettlement of refugees from
afghanistan and you actually president
mentioned the question of aid for those
member states that step up and are
willing to react um and because one of
those countries that have voluntary is
indeed spain and they're hosting right
now some of those evacuees i was
wondering if there is already a plan to
resettle those people from spain to
different member states and if not when
can we expect that um and maybe because
this is the question again about
voluntary resettlement the the role of
the different member states um can we
expect an european council to be
organized in the coming days to try to
coordinate all these different measures
thank you
so um first of all their
resettlement is voluntary without any
question
and indeed the resettlement forum i was
mentioning initially that that we have
in place so a structure that does exist
that
is experienced in tackling those topics
is in a phase of pledging
um of course this has to be then focused
on the question of afghanistan but
there it is important to have a
coordinated approach and i think this
global forum
this international forum is the right
response for a crisis of the
international
of international dimension in
afghanistan it's not an eu
related but it is the international
community
resettlement is voluntary
indeed
i know that the member states the
european commission itself cannot
resettle but because there is no
territory that the european commission
has
so um they need to be for example
humanitarian visa
they are given by uh by the member
states of course the member states
themselves are at the moment being um
discussing among uh them
the question of those who have been
evacuated who have the humanitarian
visas
and
who
indeed try now to find a final
destination
i
think it will be certainly
a question that will be tackled in the
next days in the appropriate council
formation with the ministers for
internal uh foreign interior um for yeah
for the interior and migration because
that's where these this these questions
have to be dealt with initially within
the european union i'm
convinced that it is also high time
in this respect to discuss
how to move forward with the pact for
migration and asylum it is of utmost
importance because this gives us the
instruments
to deal with these situations to get out
of ad-hoc reactions
and to go into a system where we have
the management tools that we need
and therefore there are many reasons uh
to to push really for uh improvement or
progress on the file in the european uh
council and in the in the european
parliament and in the council formation
contact
we'll try again with lawrence norman
from the wall street journal lawrence
yeah
let's try it again is that better yes
excellent and president michelle with
respect
we're not asking you to speak to the us
but we are asking
what was president biden's response
your concerns and european concerns
about the airport shutting on august
31st
did he leave open the possibility that
it would be extended beyond this
you can please go to the microphone
otherwise we can't translate your
question
i'm still new so uh
i don't know how it works yet um i have
a question about a remark of mr burrell
yesterday about this uh reaction force
of 50 000 people that is uh announced
mr morrell yesterday talked about a kind
of intervention force of 50 000 people
does the commission and does
the council support this idea
i'm not aware of that
sorry
you don't understand me we have
understood you but i'm not aware of this
comment okay
sorry
are you
thank you for this question this
concludes our press conference thank you
for tuning in and see you soon
your call will be disconnected
[Music]
you